This project begins like
most development projects,
with a list of new
technologies to learn.
This can be a daunting stage,
but it can be exciting too.
Let's walk through the list.
For the meme editor,
we start out with picking an image
with the UI Image picker controller.
[SOUND] And the next step is editing and
correctly displaying text, moving
the view to accommodate the keyboard.
And sharing the meme
with the activity view.
And for the sent memes pages, you'll
need to set up a tab view controller.
Learn to use collection
view controllers.
And share a single data model
across multiple view controllers.
We recommend that you start out the app
by creating the meme editor, and
worry about storing
the sent memes later.
In the upcoming sections will guide you
through the steps to learn these new
skills.